how much better off would we be as
students and academic researchers if we
could just forget the hype about AI
writing tools and instead learn the
writing skills that are needed to write
a good literature review the future of
learning is here and it's called chat
GPT a new era of AI for research has
begun enter artificial intelligence
better known as ai ai tools AI tools
generative AI generative AI generative
ai ai is here and AI is here to stay
just yeah it's amazing it seems like
every day there's a new AI writing tool
that promises to cut down the amount of
time it takes to conduct and write up
academic research using AI I'm using
generative AI using AI tools at every
single step proof reading editing
finding research papers writing outlines
it's all taken care for you and to be
fair these tools do offer some
conveniences especially when it comes to
writing literature reviews if you're
doing your literature review and you
just want to do it as fast as possible
you will be able to do that in a
fraction of a Time automate this process
automation automate your literature
review writing I'll be honest writing a
literature review is a thankless task
they're often considered a boring but
necessary part of writing up academic
research something you do as an
afterthought and the final result is
often criticized and never praised I
mean think about it when was the last
time you were reading an academic report
and thought to
wow this literature review is very well
written they're boring and on the flip
side the literature review is usually
one of the main targets of criticism
whenever an article is going through
peer review so it's totally
understandable that there are so many
academics these days who have been
Outsourcing the writing of literature
reviews to these AI writing tools and
with all the money that's been flowing
into AI Industries lately it's no wonder
that there are so many influencers who
have sold their souls to these companies
and have been flooding you with content
about how to use the latest AI writing
tool to do your academic research feels
like cheating cheat do their assignments
they're not going to learn cheating is
not unethical but as an English
Professor let me tell you that they are
not fooling anyone I mean think about it
academics we read and write for a living
it's how we buy our food it's how we
keep the lights
on hello the editors of the journals
that you want to publish in know the
difference between quality academic
research and the glib text that's just
being churned out by the latest AI
writing tool and if that difference
isn't obvious to you then you don't
stand a chance of getting published in
any high impact journal the fact is that
good literature reviews are not just
lists of previous research instead they
all share one quality in common so in
today's video I'm going to reveal that
quality show you how you can use it in
different types of literature reviews
and then I'm going to share with you
some some real examples of common
criticisms about literature reviews that
come up in peer review to start though
we need to work out what kind of
academic writer you are to make sure
that you know how to use everything I'm
about to teach you so let me ask you a
question are you a researcher or a
scholar researchers are your typical
graduate students they're all finished
with coursework and they're really
excited about starting their own
independent research of course they do
have some knowledge of the field and
previous research that has happened but
they haven't gone into it too in depth
because they're too excited about
starting their own research and making a
dent in their own academic field for
that reason researchers typically write
their literature reviews after they've
done their experiment it's a kind of
afterthought something that they have to
write in order to get the entire
research report published Scholars on
the other hand do have an in-depth
understanding of the field and all the
research that's previously been done on
a given topic topic they can also see
the connections between them they know
all the shortcomings and limitations and
implications of all the research and
they're able to use this research to
guide the design of future experiments
for that reason Scholars will typically
write their literature review before
they conduct their research before
they've even designed the experiment
because they know that a literature
review serves as the basis of quality
research in a world of researchers
be a scholar amateur academics behave
like researchers they consider the real
meat and potatoes of the study to be
their own research and the literature
review is just a kind of catalog of all
the previous research that's been done
something you have to kind of churn out
in order to get your own paper published
and if that's your take if that's what
you think a literature review is then go
ahead and use one of these AI writing
tools to compose it for you it doesn't
matter because nobody's going to read it
but the academics who are publishing
quality research that which advances the
collective understanding of the
discourse Community are the scholars the
ones who understand that the literature
review is the first step to Quality
academic research so that's why in The
Writing Center at my University we're
always telling graduate students that in
order to become a researcher you have to
first become a scholar but in order to
become a scholar you've got to know what
type of literature review is right for
you you know how in academic research
you've got to make sure that the
methodology is appropriate for your
research question to make sure you're
using the right tools to gather that
data well the same thing is true in
academic writing before you write the
literature review You've got to consider
what methods you'll use to gather and
synthesize past research you got to
think about things like are you going to
cover only the most recent studies
because that's the current state of the
field or are you going to try to give an
exhaustive summary of all the research
that's been done on a given topic are
you going to spend time looking at the
different controversies and
disagreements in the field are you going
to be putting each piece of research
under the microscope and showing what's
wrong with it critiquing it or are you
just going to kind of list the major
findings from each of these studies and
how are you going to lay all of this out
is it going to be chronologically by
time or are you going to be grouping
these Studies by their points of view or
even the countries where they were
conducted these are all things you're
going to have to think about when you
are planning out your literature revew
but to make things simple let's just
take a look at probably the most common
type of literature review which is
called The Narrative literature review
that's where the writer basically
chooses whichever research he thinks is
relevant to the current study it's loose
it's it's not so important that the
writer covers all the research that's
been done on a given topic he just
basically chooses whichever ones he
thinks will help develop the background
of his research and organizes them into
some coherent pattern and to help you
write your own narrative literature
review we're going to take a look at at
some real examples of common criticisms
that have come up for literature reviews
in peer review but first let's take a
quick look at three other types
systematic literature reviews are a lot
more strict than the narrative type and
they usually include the criteria that
was used for selecting the research this
is something like the method section in
a scientific report it includes detailed
information about the methodology so
that if another writer were to come and
try to write the same systematic
literature review and followed the
methods they would wind up writing
essentially the same report and that is
supposed to make the research a lot more
objective and eliminate author bias
because it prevents writers from just
selecting research from their own
friends or peer group there are
different use cases for this type of
literature review but it's definitely
more common in the Health Sciences where
clinicians need to integrate Research
into their practice next up is the meta
analysis which brings together data from
multiple studies that have all examined
the same research question but what
makes the meta analysis unique is that
it doesn't merely catalog these previous
studies but instead it uses statistical
methods to draw out findings across all
studies and finally there are some
literature reviews that Focus only on
one particular aspect of previous
research like the methodology or
bibliography so let's say for example
you are a graduate student who is
preparing to conduct some of your own
research your supervisor might ask you
to begin by conducting a methodological
literature review in which you examine
the designs methods and approaches that
have been used in the past on the same
topic after conducting such a focus
literature review you're going to be in
a good position to identify where the
holes are and what new methodologies
should be used in designing your
experiment for a second example at my
University we often ask graduate
students to write a bibliographic
literature review before beginning work
on their dissertation this kind of lit
review ensures that students have an
in-depth understanding of the field
before they set out on their own
research and essentially make sure that
they are Scholars before they become
researchers that's what a bibliographic
literature review can do for you and
that in-depth understanding is what AI
writing tools will never give you so now
that you've ditched the AI writing tools
and have transformed from a researcher
into a scholar you're ready to write but
there are still a few common mistakes
that come up again and again in
literature reviews so I thought I would
just save you the pain of peer review by
pointing out to you now let's take a
look at these five examples of real
comments from peer review about
literature reviews to see if they would
apply as well to your literature review
your literature review mainly lists past
research papers without highlighting
their relative importance it shows that
you've done a lot of research but it
lacks Clarity on which studies are most
and least important this makes it
difficult to understand your perspective
your review is presented in
chronological order that's suitable for
a textbook but not as an introduction to
your research your selection and
description of past research should be
influenced by your your research
hypothesis but I don't see any
relationship between the two it's
important to more clearly highlight the
relevant themes and issues your review
starts with theoretical aspects
referencing wellknown theorists and then
movees to practical recent empirical
studies currently there's a lack of
clear connection between these two
sections it's challenging but necessary
to create coherence between them the
review appropriately details each
relevant research piece but reads like a
collection of separate summaries it
requires a more overarching approach
that evaluates and interconnects these
studies conducting interdisplinary
reviews is hard and I understand your
struggle yet your review remains
confined within traditional disciplinary
limits for Innovation it's essential to
draw more links between different
disciplines revealing new connections
and relationships you aim to establish
so if you want to avoid these common
mistakes then here are some Pro tips
that you can use in writing your
literature review one don't just
summarize synthesize remember AI writing
tools are language producing machines
they're not thinking machines and they
will never be a substitute for what is
the most important quality of literature
reviews which is evidence of an
organizing mind at work so make sure
that your literature review goes beyond
summarizing previous research make sure
that you analyze it and show the
connections between these pieces of
research and how they relate to your
study this is something that can only be
done by a mind like yours second set
your priorities you need to make value
judgments about what research is more
important and less important in your
literature review AI writing tools will
be able to spit out a list of all the
relevant research but they'll never be
able to make decisions such as what's
more important and what's less important
that is only something that can be done
by an organizing mind Ad work such as
your own third push the boundaries look
for connections outside your own
discipline combining insights from
various Fields can lead to new
Innovations and understandings in your
own research area another one of the
criticisms talked about how the
literature review was organized
chronologically which made it read more
like a textbook so in order to avoid
that kind of criticism on your
literature review you need to go check
out this video next because it's going
to give you the different patterns of
organization you can use in writing your
literature review so be sure to go check
it
out